comenzó el refuerzo oriental de la otan
esta mañana una avioneta aterrizó en el
sur de polonia con un grupo de altos
mandos militares estadounidenses el
arribo de los oficiales no identificados
forma parte del contingente de 3.000
soldados pertenecientes a la 82 brigada
aerotransportada de los eeuu que
permanecerán temporalmente en la nación
europea por orden del presidente joe
biden comienza pagando por chips este
apoyo que nos llega es también un signo
de solidaridad aliada y muestra de que
juntos somos más fuertes podemos confiar
unos en otros cerca de allí se preparan
las condiciones logísticas para el
alojamiento de los efectivos quienes
están arribando desde el viernes en la
noche
la presencia estadounidense divide la
opinión de los residentes en la zona
en general estoy en contra de que
polonia interfiera en los asuntos de
ucrania todo es humo y espejos es todo
pero creo que es una buena medida creo
que todavía no hay suficientes tropas y
debemos esforzarnos por reunir más en
este contexto las maniobras militares no
cesan este sábado la flota del pacífico
rusa realizó ejercicios en el estrecho
de la perú próximo al mar de japón al
tiempo que dos bombarderos estratégicos
sobrevolaron belarús
mientras la guardia nacional de ucrania
desarrolló maniobras entre los edificios
abandonados de la zona de exclusión de
chernóbil cerca de la frontera
bielorrusa y a poco más de 130
kilómetros de kiev la capital de ucrania